it may be surprising to learn that one
of the main questions that we discuss
academically about religion is one that
may seem pretty obvious to a lot of
people
what even is religion
there may be answers to these questions
like it's a set of beliefs or it's a way
of life but
these answers are often projections of
one's own religious tradition
and doesn't necessarily apply
universally
in the study of religions there have
been many theories about what religion
is all about
why are people religious why do people
believe why do people identify as
christian or
hindu or muslim for example max
weber presented a theory that religion
is basically
a way for people to create meaning in a
seemingly meaningless
world and following in his line is also
clifford geertz who wrote a very famous
definition for religion where he defines
it to
to summarize it as to create order in
chaos basically
on the other hand the sociologist emil
durkheim defined religion
in not surprisingly very sociological
terms
that religion is primarily a question of
group identity
and social belonging so simply put there
is a lot of theories and a lot of ideas
about what religion or
belief comes from or what it consists of
there are a lot of questions but not a
lot of definitive answers
but i think these questions are still
worth asking why does someone identify
as christian or
muslim for that matter what is belief
and what does that term
mean to people who do believe or to
researchers like us
there is research that may partly at
least answer this question
[Laughter]
[Applause]
in 2001 there was a census study made in
the uk
which revealed that 72 percent of the
population
identified themselves as christian this
number was much higher than expected
which puzzled a lot of people
could that much of the population really
be devout christians who go to church or
believe in god
the scholar and sociologist abby day was
very skeptical of this and suspected
that the methodology used by the census
was questionable
as a result she did an investigation of
her own trying to answer the same
questions
but using a different method thus diving
into the complex world of belief
and coming up with some very interesting
results
firstly day is skeptical and critical of
the methodology used by the census study
as of course methodology has a huge
impact on the
results of a study like this the census
study is this
huge undertaking where a whole massive
amount of the population in this case in
the uk
is studied and the way they do this is
by handing them
questionnaires where they have a few
answers to choose from
and this is highly questionable when it
comes to studying religion as
it very much fails to capture the very
complex
nature of religious affiliation identity
and beliefs day in her own research
tries to tackle this from a completely
different
approach belief is a very complex
term and what she wants to do is to
counter those who use the term quote
without analyzing or
theorizing what they or the people they
study mean
that is by the word belief at the most
basic level
she does in-depth interviews with her
informants
rather than just handing them a
questionnaire with a few choices
she also does a conscious decision not
to include what she calls religious
questions or to avoid using overtly
religious vocabulary and
concepts this was done in order to avoid
the common problem that many researchers
tend to ask questions that require
certain answers
and instead to explore people's beliefs
from a more
neutral standpoint she finds that while
many informants
would identify as christian if given a
choice of options
this doesn't really say anything about
their theological or philosophical views
on life or the world
indeed many of the informants are
atheist or agnostic but still
identify as being christians and this
may not be that surprising to some but
how can we explain it when talking about
belief and religion in the modern
western primarily world
the sociologist grace davey coined the
very famous term
believing without belonging that is
people
in modern secularized western countries
tend to
believe in things still things like
spirits or
gods or the afterlife or things like
this but that they do not feel like they
belong to a certain religious
tradition or institution we find this
position a lot it's kind of well
exemplified by the spiritual but not
religious
term that we've seen thrown around
commonly and this is a view that is very
accepted today
people still believe in things very
strongly but they don't belong
to the traditional religious
institutions in these to the same degree
abby day doesn't disagree with this in a
way she kind of affirms it
but she also adds her own spin to it she
adds to the term or she
she you could say she edits the term a
little bit from believing
without belonging to her own term which
is believing
in belonging which is also the title of
her excellent book in which she presents
this research what she's doing is
arguing that belief
is first and foremost a question of
identity
when her informants say they are
christian they do so primarily for
reasons related to identity
some of them call themselves christian
only because they were baptized
others because it marked their identity
as different from the
non-european others who they saw as
intruders in britain
these were what she calls members of a
performative
christianity who identified as
christians for social reasons
a form of community or belonging quote
to be a christian for them did not
include participating in liturgy or
ritual
or engaging with christian principles
such as faith in god the resurrection or
the life of jesus
it only required being named or
attending church when children
or being part of what they described as
a christian
culture the fact is most of these
informants when
asked what they believe in even those
who were not part of this performative
christianity group
very much emphasized relationships and
family
when asked what they believe for example
young people tended to express believing
in family and friends
their belief was what they calls
anthropocentric
their orientation was to people and not
necessarily to
gods half of these christians either
overtly disavowed religion completely or
they never incorporated christianity or
god or jesus
into their discussions and the majority
of her informants had very little
interest in
religious or metaphysical questions as
such
they concludes that belief is primarily
of a social nature
that the function of belief is to make
people feel like they belong
whether that be to a family or a
community or a church and so on
a very important point that she makes is
that beliefs are so-called performative
that if they are shaped by the
performative social relations that the
person takes part in
this means that one's belief is very
strongly interconnected
with one's nationality family group of
friends and so on
in other words people believe in their
social relationships
quote believing in belonging to a
particular culture
is nevertheless actively demonstrated
and the claims vigorously supported by
demonstrating
adherence to certain social truths or
facts
that are presented as self-evident the
facts
offered in evidence of membership in the
culture help strengthen impermeable
boundaries
that define who has the right to belong
the act of claiming that identity is
what i describe
as performative it brings into being a
social reality for the informant and
provides a comforting sense of cultural
homogeneity
it may do so by relying both on already
held beliefs and on assumptions that are
preformed
adjusting them to particular
circumstances to performing them
in that case it does not depend on the
number of times a particular act is
performed
but upon what butler referred to as the
binding power of the act
and thus i will argue helps reproduce a
certain idea
of a certain culture this also leads to
the fact that belief
through this performative process
includes a very strong sense of the
other or the out group this becomes
especially clear as many of the
informants often blame many of society's
problems on for example
muslims who they see as being foreign
and different from the inherent
christian culture which to them results
in a clash
in other words even people who may not
believe in god or adhere to certain
theological
doctrines still very much identify with
a certain
christian culture that is identified in
opposition
to another when asked what they believe
in which is a very
neutral broad question these informants
often emphasize morality
and good behavior as examples of what
they believe in
for example one informant called barry
when asked the simple question what he
believes in
he answered what do i believe in i
believe in right and wrong i believe in
having good morals i believe in honor
and this is a very common stance
throughout the study people tend to
emphasize that they believe in morality
and mean being a good person
which sometimes takes the linguistic
form of quote-unquote being
a good christian for one informant being
a good christian is defined by doing
good things and helping other people
as he tells an example where he helps
some ambulance personnel
so even for those who do use a more
religious language belief or in this
case
being a good christian is also strongly
connected to social morality and much
less so to
theological beliefs or rituals but at
the same time this morality is not
necessarily universal
when people say they believe in treating
people fairly
the words people and fair are not
necessarily neutral or universal terms
instead it often constitutes
a certain group of people that one
considers to be one's kin
they writes quote informants often raise
the specter of an other
often ethically or racially constituted
young or female
as responsible for immoral behavior this
leads obviously to
legitimizing prejudice against the other
but also that the informants often
distance themselves from
responsibilities regarding social
problems
they thus claims that belief is quote
performed through social actions
of both belonging and excluding
so while we may assume that when people
say they are christians this means they
belong to a certain category
regarding practices or beliefs this
study shows that this necessarily isn't
the case at all
belief instead is a term that is very
complex and broad
and can mean very different things both
to informants
and to the researchers themselves
according to abby day and her research
belief is thus mainly a question of
performative identity formation and
social
relationships now this is just a very
simple
summary of the contents of her research
which is
summarized or written in her book
believing in belonging
so if you're interested in knowing more
about this subject and studying further
i highly suggest you pick this book up
it's become somewhat of a
modern classic in the academic field of
religion now we should remember that
this research was done in britain
and so the findings the results could be
very centralized and specific to that
region
we may assume maybe that if we study
countries in western or central europe
or maybe the united states
we would end up with similar answers or
similar results
but could the same be said for a country
like china or
iraq or other countries in the middle
east maybe not but this
remains to be studied and for further
research to be done on it
but what abby day has proposed here and
as i've said multiple times already
is that belief is primarily about
identity
social relationships and performative
constructions
of belonging let's discuss this further
in the comments and if you want to
support the channel
you can like the video or subscribe to
the channel
i'll see you next time
[Music]
you